tonight marks the end of an era for TV
comedy after 279 episodes the Big Bang
Theory is coming to an end the hit CBS
show is now the longest-running
multi-camera comedy in TV history
it has provided nearly 12 years of lacks
with some of televisions most endearing
and unique characters Big Bang Theory is
about for eggheads and their women who
love that you're a vixen Amy Farrah
Fowler
then your much simpler than that since
last time you saw me naked I got a
cookie monster tattoo you acceptable
responses when you see it are awesome or
nothing if penny can fall in love with
one of these guys then the rest of us
can yes I'll marry you
you will sheldon for god sakes don't
make me beg
bazinga say Big Bang Theory what comes
to mind bazinga
you think it's gonna be the first thing
people say bazinga
Zynga the secret sauce for the Big Bang
Theory is pretty much the secret sauce
for any show that lasts a long time and
that's the perfect alchemy of actors mmm
Leonard took me to the barber and the
dentist and then to cap off the perfect
day the Los Angeles Bureau of weights
and measures the fact that people want
to invite these characters in this cast
into their houses and hang out with them
penny penny is just this little piece of
magic
bazinga is certainly now part of the
culture The Big Bang Theory stars kaley
cuoco and Johnny Galecki and they join
us at the table good morning and karate
Congrats tube thank you it was so
touching yesterday guys at upfront which
is a civic CBS unveiling to advertisers
when the cast walked out everybody gave
you all the standing ovations you could
tell that everybody up there was
surprised and moved that was true yeah
standing ovations at Carnegie Hall were
really touched by that and a little
emotional you show this beautiful video
it was just a lovely tribute but I'm
wondering how you're feeling I know
everybody knows it's time I get that but
Chuck Lorre described it as grateful and
grief-stricken and that a good way to
describe guys yeah it's very yeah I
think I keep the quote from Winnie the
Pooh keeps coming up and my mother how
lucky I am to be this sad to say goodbye
to something you know we all feel very
very grateful but the timing is right
yeah it's kind of like a death in a way
you know I mean it's been a long long
time together so nobody described it as
being like going from kindergarten to
12th grade with people the whole time
which I thought was a good actually we
did the at our show we did a yearbook so
it went from day one to the last day and
it was literally a yearbook and people
on the last day we're having their
friends sign it and the crew members and
shaking it was really kind of a sweet
gesture and no show was had the ratings
like this too you guys have just been a
blockbuster success for such a long
period and I love Chuck Lorre describing
essentially that when he first brought
it to CBS they said yeah there's no
thing no thing because you guys have
been involved in a lot of television
what's the lesson do you think behind
that mm-hmm I think it initially I mean
Chuck would say that the script wasn't
quite there in that first pilot and a
very different pilot very different
pilot
yes aesthetically it was very different
but I think most importantly we didn't
have Kaylee and Simon and Kunal and when
when that happened to min there was just
a synergy there and that whatever that
elusive chemistry is that you can't
really create was was there in Kaylee
have you had people come out I think of
my own kids among we watched the show
together with them
who have I mean their lives they've gone
through those 12 years it makes me feel
quite old I think she was like 10 I
loved the show I was like oh when did
you start watching she's like well it
started before I was born
[Laughter]
cuz we ages so I mean we get yeah 80
year olds it's reached so many different
people maybe the timeline for certain
people's lives they all get around a you
know and talk about the various seasons
of the show grew up on the show we have
shows that we grew up right now we love
ya that won't be for someone else yeah
everybody was raving about the finale I
talked to a lot of your colleagues in
Chuck too they said they think the
finale is perfection and that it's
emotional and not everything ends with a
neat little bow but everybody gets to
shine in these last episodes three
finales are so there's been so many of
them that have been so well done so
brilliant from so many wonderful shows
and so many that have not been well done
it's hard that's there's a lot of
pressure a lot of anxiety for months on
how this is going to end for the writers
and for us too and I'm really try not to
be biased but it's one of the sweetest
finales I think I've ever seen like this
I don't know how someone could not enjoy
this
it's very heartfelt in a time where I
feel like we need I don't know it's just
it's kind every character does have a
wonderful moment and it's beautiful a
few months ago I was asked to name my
top five favorite episodes and it was
nearly impossible for me to do it yeah
they all kind of melt together over the
years but I can honestly say now that's
very the last three episodes are by far
my favorite the one with Christine
Baranski plays your mother that's
already aired because she's such a
caustic person in the episode the two of
you have been very interesting dynamic
and I kept waiting for the joke to come
between the two of you when you sort of
resolved it and it didn't which I
thought was unexpected yeah I did too it
was one of those you know in fact and
Christine said the same thing when we
first read the script we thought we read
it wrong we were missing a page it's not
it was an incredible gift of trust that
they gave she and I the writers
because that's not necessarily a proven
moment and multi-camera love audience
sitcom to not end a scene on a joke to
let the drama of the scene ring out I'm
really proud of that episode and she's
just a dream to work with obviously they
say this show was approached episode by
episode what does that mean guys I
didn't know what that meant
so most shows are weeks ahead already
our show our writers they really write
for each week so they're not we're not
technically ahead in scripts they kind
of like to see how the storylines go so
a lot of people over the years are like
what's gonna happen over the next few
episodes our writers didn't even know
and they would kind of play it by ear so
I we were like a week ahead barely a
week ahead and it's airy and it's just
kind of what worked for our show I'm
curious about your next chapters because
Johnny's good friend came up to him and
said he has the biggest heart one of the
smartest brains and he's a really good
musician Johnny what's yours Kaley I
started my production company a year and
a half ago and we've got a lot of stuff
in development I'm enjoying the
producing hats actually yeah a new path
for me right Johnny
well quickly Johnny I'm yeah mine's
coming okay everybody stay tuned thank
you so much
you can watch the series finale of The
Big Bang Theory tonight in two
back-to-back episodes starting at 8:00
7:00 central right here on CBS